search and rescue workers in the Florida
Panhandle have now accounted for
thousands of hurricane michel survivors
in the hardest hit areas President Trump
and the first lady traveled there
yesterday to see the devastation and
offer their support firsthand
Omar Villafranca is in Mexico Beach
Florida where the recovery is still in
its earliest stages Omar good morning to
you good morning Mexico Beach police
compiled a list of 230 people who said
they were gonna ride the storm out in
their home and after search crews
started going house-to-house searching
like this one here and debris piles as
well then we're able to whittle that
list down from 2:30 to 3 people
unaccounted for and the president's
visit here yesterday was a signal to
many that they have not been forgotten
nearly a week after Michael ravaged the
Panhandle President Trump arrived to
tour the disaster zone when you're above
it in a plane and to see the total
devastation
the president also flew over Mexico
Beach where crews with dogs continue to
search for bodies in piles of debris the
widespread destruction has prompted the
governor to consider revisiting the
region's building codes after Michael
roared ashore with winds up to 155 miles
per hour this is one of the few homes in
Mexico Beach left standing it was
reportedly built to withstand 250 mile
an hour winds on high pilings with
reinforced concrete but newly
constructed coastal buildings here are
only required to handle winds reaching
150 miles per hour
and while florida regulations require
homes to be built with fortified roofs
and reinforced concrete pillars many
structures in the area were built before
those restrictions went into effect the
relief effort now involves more than
4,000 National Guardsmen and 17,000
utility workers but recovery is slow
in Panama City people lined up for gas
yesterday but what they're running out
of is patience
people is sleeping in their cars I'm
sleeping in my car with four kids two
adults we got nowhere to go cellphone
companies like AT&T and Verizon are
working to improve connectivity in the
area power situation is still not great
there's roughly about 125,000 people in
Florida who still do not have any power
here locally in Mexico Beach I talked to
the mayor and he told me he does not
expect to have power maybe even water
for at least two months John Omar thanks
you really get a sense of the
devastation almost a week since the
storm has hit Thank You Omar